if this guy could make me squirt I'm
going over there yeah and you can't do
it that's fair yo that's fair that's
fair I get it that happened to me man
[Music]
so since you have advised like other
only fans creators on how best to like
begin their platform and stuff
um I wanted to go through this recent
deal that this one Creator had and I
want to know if this is a good deal if
it's a good little situation yeah if
it's a good situation so there's this um
there's this Creator named Gainer
McKinnon and she's her name is gay okay
yeah that's a pretty gay ass name so uh
she she ran this special where she did a
raffle and uh for 20 bucks she's selling
20 tickets and if you're the lucky
winner of this raffle then you get to
have sex with her I actually
an opportunity for my fans to have an
experience with me for the disabled with
um yeah that was that was me that was
pretty cool specifically I wanted to do
thank you for your service not like a
Make-a-Wish but I just wanted to give
people a [__] a fan disabled people are
horny bro yeah dude our Justice
everyone's horny they need love too man
and they're sentient and this oh is that
the one with Jimmy yeah yeah okay yeah
and he was like this guy
um he was completely legally blind or is
completely legally blind he's heard my
voice on podcasts and he knows I'm Asian
and what I was like do you know what I
look like he was like I know you're
Asian I was like okay does he have the
Ray Charles powers do you know Ray
Charles blade grab you oh you're [__]
hot as [__]
I knew I must have been a hot girl based
off of like the social constructs around
how people treat me maybe okay but um
yeah we had an experience and it was
cool nice
was he very touchy like really feeling
he was obviously really nervous because
first of all you're blind second of all
is this really happening like is Kazumi
actually having like did she actually
fly out to have sex with me in this
hotel or like who the [__] is this
person wow yeah and I remember being
like are you an ass person or a titty
person and he was like titties bro
and I could tell he was just like
wow I gotta remember this I wonder what
was like the thank you for whatever
Vision that was going on in his brain it
was just pulsating music it was like
[__] Neo in The Matrix the first time
he was like oh I am doing another
situation for fans right now for short
Kings because I feel like short kings
are the most discriminated type of guy
yeah well are you talking about like
four guys that are 410 and stuff or like
I haven't started getting a bunch of
guys who are like five and that's not
short that's not I'm five three you're
taller than me
than me like like I did [__] a little
person once because he told me he was
Wee Man but he doesn't need
you man but
I swear to for the purpose of like
[__] a little person what is the
short King's Speck I think I'm 5'3 but I
tell people on the internet I'm 411
because it's hotter for their fantasies
oh
411 is a nice like yeah that's like the
opposite of NBA you know they're like
six six oh I'm six nine yeah that bro I
saw you in person was like six six I
remember I met up with a guy and he was
just like you're [__] five three dude
and I was like yeah she was like but you
said you were 4 11. and I was like you
made me want to throw up you five three
you [__] giant get the [__] out of
here get your tall ass out here I was
like I'm sorry I wish I could be four
inches shorter I'd be so much hotter if
I was foreign I wanted you to suck my
dick standing up now you're too tall now
you're doing a slight bend over yeah
[__] that people do have interesting
Kinks so is that do you think that's a
good deal twenty dollars twenty dollars
like how many people are tipping for
that well I don't know what the tips
were but she they she sold all 20 raffle
tickets yeah wait it's twenty dollars
for twenty so there's only 20 slots and
then you 20. that's the max 100 dollars
oh but in addition to that was this a
bad thing she did she published the
names of all the people that bought them
excuse me okay here is that breaking a
cardinal rules
number one number two I feel like a big
reason why I'm super successful again
I've talked about it earlier is I love
men you know and I will respect your
discretion you know like I I've like
bought [__] for my boyfriend you know
like I will buy sex I don't care like
but and I remember and I've also been a
sugar baby so I've experienced all types
of like sex work both becoming a
producer and a consumer and it's like
the most important thing is I want to
feel good you know like if I I remember
being a sugar baby with the worst
customer service and being like yo it's
been like 40 minutes like you need to
[__] finish 40 minutes yo shake
weight in it but that's because I'm not
making them like I'm not providing like
a good experience where they feel good
like I'm acting like an annoyed person
so of course they're like um I'm not
getting hard like you're not making me
feel good about myself yeah obviously
there's other reasons why that would
take longer but like when you are doing
sex work or any type of customer service
you should at least try to make them
feel good like I wouldn't want to be
embarrassed like I have a friend she's
got the fattest [__] titties I had to
subscribe to her only fans because I
needed to see nipples she won't post
nipples anywhere else really yeah I'm
like bro I'm just getting [__]
nipples
smart business model her pictures were
like yeah you like that you loser by
paying 10 bucks to see some nipples I
would feel bad
yay congrats here's some boobs I feel
good so because you achieve that level
yeah yeah you know so I would what she
did that was a little weird I don't know
I've never seen that I don't want to
feel embarrassed about buying it like I
remember me and my partner we drove to
this legal brothel and I was like dude
let me buy you like some [__] dude and
I remember yo
[Laughter]
he was like what form of trickery are
you trying to impose on me and I was
like honestly I want to just know what
it's like but if we ordered a threesome
first of all it'd be really expensive
second of all because it's legal yeah
yeah
it's [__] second of all I feel like the
experience I want is I want to know what
it's like one-on-one male to female like
not threesome situation although if
people want to have like a unicorn
situation I do feel like they should pay
for the experience rather than just
going to a bar and having like finding
like a random normal girl and subjecting
them to your fantasies I feel like there
are people who will provide your sexual
fantasies and you can pay them that
makes sense actually yeah so were you
just gonna pay and then go to the bar
and have a drink or would you want to
watch remember what happened was he they
separated us so he like went in and he
like did that thing where all the girls
line up and he chooses the girl me they
put me they kept me in like would look
like a dentist's office with a bunch of
like snacks and I watched South Park and
I remember it was 30 minutes the whole
South Park episode and maybe the intro
the first one and then he came out and
he was like
[Laughter]
drove home and it was happier
who was experience and everything he was
like it was an interesting experience
because what I wanted to know is I
wanted to know does it feel like you're
just having sex with someone or does it
feel like you paid for it yeah and he
was like it feels like you're having sex
with someone oh wow because we're that
good at providing this yeah and I was
like that's like something I want to
provide I wanted to feel I mean I do but
I wanted to feel like I do this because
I want to do you feel jealous at all a
little bit jealousy is a is a normal
human emotion but also consider this
like if I'm not a deep rotor but if he
finds a girl that can deep program
I'm not like who am I to take that
experience away that's true because
because
he's with
him all women it goes the other way too
right if you can't eat your [__] the
right way if this guy can make me squirt
I'm going over there yeah and you can't
do it that's fair yo that's fair that's
fair I get it that happened to me man
I get it but it's like he's with me for
reasons Beyond sex you know like when I
go on dates with people primarily I'm
trying to [__] you and then if I like
you enough I would see you again you can
separate them maybe we could eat or go
in public and go to shop at Trader Joe's
that's kind of extreme why do you think
like a guy I don't think
like I think just like a 25 year old
woman and I feel like we're just not
brave enough to say it so there's a lot
of 25 year old women that think like you
but they're ashamed of it or what is it
I don't feel like they're ashamed I feel
like they just don't feel safe because
when I talk to a woman a lot of these
women have like fantasies about gang
bangs about doing this and that but they
also are like scared of the social
consequences of what it would feel like
if men didn't take them seriously or if
they didn't provide them certain
opportunities like for me like sex is a
part of my career so I'm not afraid of
that becoming a thing that happens
whereas like if I was just a girl going
to the gym working with my gym homies
and I said something sexual I wouldn't
want you to see it as an opportunity but
more so just me providing a fun company
I'm just [__] around just like how
you do I'm just being silly yeah just
make a silly guy if you're trying to be
a lawyer or something it might ruin your
career yeah which sucks when I was on
office girl I was such a horny person it
was kind of silly in the share a little
bit more than silly I was like a
marketing executive but I also like love
to bring my co-workers to sex parties
because that was just like a good first
date for me dude that's a human
resources nightmare dude but I was also
I was like at the time I was like top
three in the country for what I was
doing like which was in marketing and
sales so I felt like I just was a good
asset also I just was I don't know it
somehow it was cool I also had a good
asset that was my girl privilege talking
because I never got in trouble for that
that's dope what was what's what's horny
at work for you what do you mean like
currently now no because you said you
were super horny at work so were you
like going to the bathroom no like I
would bring them to sex parties and then
I would watch my co-workers like like I
would let them watch me get railed you
know for fun also you would also be
performing yeah so it's not like let's
just go watch together
you can watch me perform yeah
yeah join but usually they'd be really
shy and being like being like like well
I'm trying to keep my job you're not
gonna get me and then next time you're
at work together they don't it's not
weird it never really was weird but I
also like I only have sex with people I
have a lot of sex but I only have sex
with people that respect me and I think
that's first and foremost like I can
kind of vet out if a guy under if a guy
understands me and makes me feel safe so
I wouldn't just like talk to a random
like guy that's like insane you know
like yeah yeah
it's a true FDF yeah FCF I can tell that
you're sentient you know you're like not
just like a ball of genitals
which I feel like most dudes are yeah
like I feel like but like now that I'm
an older woman embracing like my whole
hortivities has really surrounded me
with fortuities I like learning so much
you should meet with men that make me
feel very understood like I feel like
the men that are around me like don't
see it as an opportunity to [__] me but
they see it as like you know it's like
celebration no sweatshirt yeah let's
celebrate you need more people to be
like this around you yeah yeah yeah
and it's like and it's like I like
relate to like it's just like I don't
find love an exclusive thing physically
I think we can share all of that you
know if we can provide if we can have
the right communication all the time you
think you're gonna get married to your
boyfriend yeah
[Music]
of way to date someone but like when I
we went to the swingers resort there was
a lot of people that were much older
than me there were a lot of people that
have been like like married for 20 years
and they just opened up their marriage
and there's people that are curious so
I'm lucky enough that first of all I'm
doing this younger so I can experience
everything I want while still coming
home to someone that like loves me yeah
that's really cool stable and and on top
of that he's able to I'm his first
girlfriend it's cool and he could [__]
other woman like what like that's really
cool oh boy got lucky boy
he spoke on his career so he doesn't
really [__] as much but it's like cool
to see the opportunity of like not
losing your life over A Moment Like if I
were to meet someone at a coffee shop
and then he talks to me and he raises me
up and then I like get eaten out in the
bathroom I'd like to know that I don't
lose everything when I come home yeah
yeah you know I don't think it's that
serious it's just a moment and sometimes
when people like question me about it
they're like oh I don't think I would do
it I'm like the chances of me and him
leaving each other for another person is
just as likely if not less likely than
what you would be in in a monogamous
relationship in a monogamous
relationship people do that anyways yeah
it's like at least I'm able to explore
and find out yeah you know and I'm able
to have my own individual experience
because you learn about someone without
the boundaries sometimes yeah because
then they're tested and then you see
what happens yeah what's your what's
your favorite animal my my favorite
animal is
um cats they're cute because it has
nothing to do with their sexual what no
I just
where are you going Bart
my closet organizer to clean my house
and I overheard them one time like you
had a closet organizer to clean organize
the rest of your house yeah because it's
[__] up
yeah I just do closets though yeah what
can you do the the whole thing no when
you like go into MTV Cribs and you see
like Flavor Flav they're not just clean
people they hire closet organizers to
organize their whole [__] house got
you like staging people yeah and I
remember I could hear them like outside
and be like wow she doesn't have a lot
of stray porn huh
they make comments
and like yeah I like Furry comics
because like they're so more detailed in
the in like the anatomy I don't know I'm
not gonna talk about it but oh yeah yeah
[Music]